all right guys
bang bang i've got a special treat today
mr caleb presley is here uh for those of
you that do not know caleb
uh he is a electric content creator is
how i would describe him
thanks so much for uh for doing this man
no problem i'm excited i told you i'm a
big fan of yours
huge fan so caleb you grew up in north
carolina or just went to unc
i grew up there born and raised
asheville north carolina which is in the
mountains
west north carolina and uh yeah then i
went to carolina for school too
so really the only time i've ever not
been in north carolina is here in new
york city
yeah that's awesome um and so let's talk
first about unc
football uh i grew up a duke fan so
we'll give you a pass
but uh what was that like playing
football uh
at unc and kind of that whole experience
well i had to i'll give you a pass
because
because my dad uh went to duke and so we
had a little bit of
duke uh affiliations as i was growing up
as well but uh
was he mad when you decided to go to
carolina no he wasn't mad but i'll tell
you this
he put a sticker on his car whenever i
went to carolina to play football and
then uh
the day i graduated he took a sticker
off caroline
right off it was it wasn't uh yeah
he wasn't feeling it so anyway it was a
great experience man
i was there for i wouldn't i went in
under butch davis
um and uh he got fired my freshman year
before my friend three days before the
season started so i got i got there in
june or july
i spent like a month or two in the
summer conditioning program meeting
everyone
all the coaching staff whatever and then
three days before the season starts
uh he gets fired for you know there was
just some apparently some cheating going
on it turns out he didn't even have
anything to do with it
but he got fired the staff
took you know this his staff was there
my freshman year but then after that
they got fired too so
and then i kind of you know i don't know
how
what your listeners are into football or
not but i went in basically butch davis
is a pro style
offense which is a different i play
quarterback that's a different type of
offense for a quarterback and then we
got a new
spread style offense after that which uh
wasn't good for me
i was not uh i'm not a prototypical
spread quarterback so
i had a great time at kevin i was a
career backup and played in a few games
and uh and i wouldn't change it for the
world
i i saw somebody tweeting at us when i
asked for questions about
you had a a very long two yard run they
said so i don't know
i think it was against idaho or
something which i figured it was
somebody that you either knew
or a carolina fan that was trying to
bust your balls no dude it was actually
historically correct there's in the card
football almanac
it's actually the longest two-yard run
in the history of the game it was almost
tell us the story almost three yards
yeah
no it was uh we were beating i think
idaho by i think it was 70 to 20.
and then the coach put me in i think it
was time to take the starters out
eventually and
and they we were running a zone
so like i'll do another inside football
thing but
we're running a run play basically zone
read
we have an attached tight end so what
what you do in a in a zone read is you
read the defensive end if he crashes on
the running back
you pull the ball well if there's a
attached tight end
then the tight end will just block that
guy that you're supposed to read and so
there really is no ability to read it as
a quarterback and you post a hand it off
let the guy go
so i'm sitting here on the sideline you
know it's 50 to 20
60 to 20. 70 to 20 finally i'll get in
so i was like i'm pulling the ball so i
basically made up my own play
and almost made it three yards
i i love that uh i joke all the time
i play football at uh bucknell
university and in high school
our team was horrible like i think we
literally went one in ten
uh for two years straight when i was a
freshman and sophomore
and so by the time i uh got to be a
senior we basically like look man we're
either
gonna have fun out here or we're gonna
lose all the time and our best play my
senior year was a fake punt
so we basically would get in fourth and
long and then we would run a fake punt
and the coach would only call it you
know once a game
and finally towards the end of the
season my friends and i just started
saying look man we're gonna run that
play all the time and so we would just
call it ourselves on the field and as
you can imagine i'm sure your coach
didn't like the fact that you pulled the
ball
or that we used to run the fake punt and
you know they want to run their system
but
hey that's what happens right yeah fake
points always good you get to the point
where you're running on third down
though that's a problem
[Laughter]
absolutely uh all right and then uh tell
us about this letter
that you wrote to the coaches what what
is that
oh you have to remind me maybe dude
so somebody said that you wrote a letter
to the coaches that had like some
ridiculous
all-time quotes in it but it's no longer
available anywhere on the internet
so this is what they're probably talking
about so i used to have when i was at
carolina
and this is kind of how i got started at
bar stool and and uh or at least it was
the origins of it was i had a website
called calebresly.com
and i would just you know i didn't have
any like aspirations to be in
uh media as a profession but
i actually was inspired by this guy
named mark titus some people might know
him he's still around
but when he was at ohio state he's a
basketball player and he kept his own
website
called club trillian and it was
hilarious like he was just always
he was a backup too he's always writing
about his interactions with like greg
odin who was there at the time and
uh just just hilarious
website so i was inspired by him so i
started my own website where i was doing
blogs i was trying to imitate him
basically it was a copycat
um and i was doing a couple videos and
it was all just to make people laugh and
for my friends really my family people
who were following me back home in
asheville
and then of course there's some carolina
fans who are deep enough in like the
message boards and stuff where they find
out about it
and so i wrote a lot of stuff on that
site
which it hasn't been necessarily deleted
i just stopped paying for it so i think
that
i think that like wordpress deleted it
but i mean i don't know i probably could
renew the
subscription and find out what they're
talking about i wrote a lot of things
and just in the interest of of
remembering it fondly and remembering it
like i was a good writer i just don't
want to renew it because i don't even
want to see it
and were you writing things like uh
covering your day-to-day life or were
you writing like let open letters to the
coaches and things like that while
you're playing
like any like literally anything like
open letters to the coaches like
demanding more playing time
i think i wrote one about like how third
i think i wrote one about thirst this is
about like basically how like
horny you guys get during the summer
during college like
um yeah i wrote a lot of things
and i'm not even sure how well they
would be remembered that's what i'm
saying so let's just i might just let
the sleeping dog lie
all right that's fair uh they might be
remember well i don't know i would
actually be interested to see
i i would love to see players today
using social media or blogs
demanding more playing time like at the
college level i think things would get
on hand very quickly
if that became the trend that's why it's
trending dude it's
it's definitely going power to the
player um do you see the pack
you see the pac-12 i saw the pack of
what do you think about that so for
those that don't know the pac-12 players
supposedly a bunch of them have come
together
and they're basically making demands
everything from uh they want
safer conditions uh during coronavirus
to they want a revenue split
uh with the conference they want uh
lifetime healthcare can all these
you know pretty uh material demands
what's your take on that
i think i think power to the player and
i think that
um that's the way it's trending that's
why it's gonna be whether you know the
ncaa
is is going to be with it or not or
these conferences are going to
of course they're going to meet it with
resistance and i don't know you know
i'm not super informed on the exact
details of what pac-12 guys are
asking for but it is going to be the way
of power to the player and not just
necessarily
on in college i mean college is where
they're probably the most
um you know they're they have the most
opportunity for growth but even in the
like professional ranks i remember
watching
i think it was last year when it's gosh
it seems like 20 years ago with
everything that's going on but i think
it was last
year antonio brown uh was
with was put out that video of john
gruden calling him
and he was at his house and it was like
he was releasing footage
that no behind the scenes footage that
you know wasn't
part of the hbo show or anything it was
just a intimate call
that he had with john gruden and he put
it out for the world to see and john
gruden i don't think knew about or maybe
he cleared it with him after
but i remember watching that and being
like one this is so interesting it's
captivating because you're seeing these
people that you really care about
operate basically behind closed doors
but what's stopping
anyone from doing this not necessarily
in just exposing conversations but just
in like
really opening the door and letting
people in i'm watching
i keep track of it i'm watching uh right
now javale mcgee from the lakers is
is doing a vlog inside the bubble
he's basically just he's filming himself
i mean it's it's pretty uh crude not in
the sense of uh
like language or anything but crude in
the sense of how it's made but
he's basically following day-to-day life
ins with the lakers and you know he's
getting on the bus and you see lebron
james in the back of the bus listen to
music it's like
that's so easy for athletes of any level
to capture
and release and people are going to be
so interested in that content and it's
something that we've really never seen
which is
behind the scenes without these big
hulking cameras which change
behaviors i do content for you know for
work
and a lot of the stuff we've done in the
past has been like
you know getting reactions out of people
or talking to people on the street or
or even like hidden camera stuff and you
always
want i always ask the producer or
whoever shooting it
let's get a smaller camera because these
big cameras change your behavior in an
instant you know we have these huge
freaking things that sit on shoulders
and we got these these audio booms and
and all of a sudden people start acting
different but if you can have these
little cameras which now just the iphone
or whatever
you capture real life it's like uh
exactly how people are and
for players to have the iphone and have
the editing ability
or to have you know a blog might even be
outdated in terms of writing
uh for players i don't know you have to
have some good writers i guess but
have you seen the matias the i think is
how you pronounce his name
from the 76ers he's been doing the same
thing and he
started on youtube maybe two three weeks
ago he's already got almost a million
subscribers
each video that he's released he's done
like six or seven of them now
uh he's gotten a million views uh on
each one i think now
no i haven't seen him that's exactly
what i'm talking about i don't see
what's stopping these guys from
because then what happens is is then all
of a sudden
you start seeing from their perspective
you start seeing from the nba players
perspective which we don't necessarily
feel bad for
nba players and pro athletes but okay
then an ncaa athlete does this
some a college football player and you
start seeing the day to day
in his life and then all of a sudden um
you start really seeing from his
perspective and then all of a sudden you
really relate to him and then
when they start making demands or when
they start asking for
um basically just to be treated fairly
and be compensated fairly then you start
being like hey this guy's right i see
what he's saying he's totally right
and right now what the ncaa has done a
really effective job doing
whether it's intentional or
unintentional is and i think it's
intentional
and it's also these college programs is
shushing the players hushing the players
where they're the only ones getting to
put their their viewpoints and their
perspective out
and so of course the public is just now
starting to come around to the idea that
maybe this is really unfair and this
the more content these athletes are able
to do um
and the more people are able to relate
to them whether it's just social media
even if it's not a vlog
the quicker this is going to change in
my opinion yeah
and i think that there you got kind of
two different things here right one is
uh the last dance if you watched that
right with the michael jordan chicago
bulls like
they filmed all of that behind the
scenes content and held it for you know
15
20 years and then they all released it
at once but it was very cut up it was
approved by michael
it was kind of espn's version of that
history
i think what you're talking about is
getting access to that information
almost in real time
and the pro players are interesting i
completely agree it's gonna happen at
the college level
but you can almost go a step further and
what stops a player from
after a game videoing uh let's say the
athletic training room right and like
look at how much pain some of these
players are in
after the game's over and you could
easily see you know some guy in a
football stadium
does that two or three games in a row
puts you know cuts it together and says
hey you want to know why we want you
know lifetime health insurance
here here's the you know the carnage
after the game's over
and look i don't think that players you
know necessarily want to go out and be
like investigative journalists or
anything like that but i do think that
uh they've got more power in their hands
now right they can do certain things
that they previously
weren't able to do which if they're
smart they can use their advantage
that's exactly what i think that's
exactly what i'm saying too and trust me
these coaches know
and the athletic directors know and the
people who are
it's in their interest to make sure that
it doesn't happen
they know how much power is in the
players hands and it's really kind of
you know a lot of i know coaches i
remember dabo sweeney a couple years ago
was like no twitter during the season
that's not so listen that's not so the
players are
focused i mean he wants him to be
focused the reason there's no twitter
during the season is he doesn't want
anything getting out
someone to say something stupid bulletin
board material for another team
or even worse some type of violation the
ncaa is going to get clemson on
they're looking out for themselves and
trust me when even when i was at
carolina
uh fedora was a coach during whatever i
was doing on my website and my content
was very receptive to me making content
he was very okay with it
and encouraged it uh in a lot of ways
but
with that being said there were
definitely still conversations that i
had with my
quarterback coach and uh and other
you know it was just well known as like
hey you if you're gonna be doing this
and you're gonna be posting you have a
responsibility not just to
yeah you can try to make people laugh
and try to be you know
you know the funny guy on the side
whatever but also this is very serious
and you need to be careful what you're
posting
and um there's a lot of power there
and i think the players are starting to
come around to that yeah and the part to
me that's so interesting about the
pac-12 thing
is there's multiple teams right this
isn't just
a couple of guys who are going you know
quote-unquote rogue from one team
they've actually gone and they're
organizing with people across the
conference and all they've done really
is they've just
made a demand right which sounds like
it's more like they sent a letter
or something like that what you're
talking about is
um when you start when you stop talking
to the ncaa you start talking directly
to the people
you could see very quickly this going
from hey
uh the ncaa is cool with you using your
image and likeness which
you know when you or i were in college
wasn't allowed to now
literally the public pressure being like
why aren't you paying these kids
right and you know if you go back to
what was it uh the ohio state guys
who like sold their cleats or something
right you know i mean and they were
getting in trouble for it and it was
like look
their argument basically was um or you
know who actually i think had the best
argument
was um arian foster right i think he
went to tennessee if i remember
correctly
and when he was in the nfl he came out
and he said uh i went into the stadium i
had like you know record day or whatever
everyone's chanting my name i went home
opened my refrigerator i had no food
and uh the quote he gave was i called
the coach and i said hey coach you
better bring me a hundred tacos or i'm
gonna do something crazy
all right and and it's like look is he
right in that situation
probably not but he's like but the coach
brought me the tacos
right and so you kind of get in this
world of like those are the stories that
people
previously were only comfortable saying
once they were nfl once they had no
repercussions
but i think that now with social media
and content people are going to start
sharing those stories in real time
right you don't want to air out your
coaches like that's you know that's a
violation the coach now i do that so
you know like when i was at carolina it
was uh coach fedor and those guys i got
i like the coaches i'm not trying to do
anything that's going to affect them
negatively that's their job they have
families there they have
they put in a lot of time most of them
really care about the players so
you know you don't want to get other
people in trouble just because you're
trying to
you know expose a flaw in the system and
that
you know that goes for more than just
college football but it's kind of a
balance of
how do you get changed without throwing
other people under the bus and hurting
what they got going on for sure talk to
me about uh bar stool
obviously uh you've gone from college
quarterback to
barstool and create some of the most
hilarious content i've ever seen
um you know you're talking earlier
account with the man on the street
or going to college campuses you know
during football season and stuff like
where do all these ideas come from
and kind of what's that process look
like from going from you know i've got
an idea to actually getting something
uh approved and published so this is
what
i think is interesting about barstool
for people who don't know is that
marshall was founded by dave portnoy who
is
who has now become he's pretty much like
a national celebrity um
he's i mean pretty much everyone knows
him whether he whatever you feel about
him
he's known so he started this company
and he basically just started it as he
wanted to be
uh for the common man by the common man
about sports sports talk
and he's grown it and he's grown it but
along the way as he's
hired new talent and i was one of the
now when we look at it now i mean i was
like the 13th employee
so i was i was early on i was before we
got bought but he still
had been going in a long time before i
came into the picture and every time he
picks up someone new
that he thinks is good for barstool he
is not overlording them basically he's
saying hey
i think that you could make a valuable
contribution to
barcelona sports and what i want from
you is i want you to go out and i want
you to create content and i want you to
publish content
and whether it's writing or it's a blog
or now a
podcast or tik tok or i guess we might
be moving to triller it sounds like but
whatever
um you know i want you to go do your
thing
and then i'm also dave's running company
but he's not like
you know ceo guy all the time he's as
you can see he's making content as well
so it's like
almost a sense of like yeah go do your
thing like
go go go for it and then whatever you
come up with and put out great he's not
checking anyone's work before it goes
out
there's no editorial process i think
there might be now for like some of the
really new guys because it
has gotten so big but um
there was never any point in my entire
career where dave
uh like was like approving
ideas after i came to him of course you
know he every once in a while he'll have
an idea for me
or if there's something like it's a
really expensive travel i'll run it you
know hey dave is this okay
and but with that being said he's never
said no in my entire career at barcelo
which is
you know five years now he's never said
no he's like the best
boss and i think it's the only way
barstool works how it does
is that it's it's complete creative
freedom
and it's like everyone's their own boss
and we have their own this little world
where
you can basically be as successful
as you want to be and put out as much
content as you want
or you can you can kind of hide in the
weeds and you'll probably still get paid
every two weeks
because dave's just not paying attention
he's focused on making
content himself and so you know people
are don't know what to feel about
barstool
because you know they maybe like say
they
like dave but they don't like you know
someone else or they like big cat but
they don't like dave
and they're like i don't understand
where is the company lying on barstool
what is the
the main point they're trying to get
across and the the
fact of the matter is there is no
editorial point
it's just a bunch of different people
who are all doing their own thing with
basically no
oversight and it's that's why it's kind
of wild
west there's no oversight but that's
what makes it fun right
that's what makes it fun yeah what do
you feel like in terms of
that process like what has it allowed
you to do that maybe you couldn't have
done elsewhere so like one or two
you know segments or pieces of content
that you've done where you're like i
know that i could have never done this
anywhere else only at barstow could have
done this
i mean almost exclusively everything i
do
that's what you're gonna say yeah i mean
there's i've
i've done it all i've done uh
i mean we've done things that are
definitely not
uh you know pg we've done
you know we've done like the porn
convention and we've done uh
we've shot out and and uh the bunny
ranch what was that
for uh out there in las vegas where
there's prostitution legal
stuff like that which is kind of more
like sultry uh stuff but also
just how we involved with sports and and
we get in there and we do stuff that's
not
i mean i went to missouri last year and
one of the things we did is like i
covered like my
uh my hydration tests my p test and it's
like just showing yourself p
i wasn't showing like nudity but just
like i videoed
myself peeing into a little jar recently
i sent my poop off to um
new mexico and we talked about that so
just there's just no
everything everything the answer is
everything so what you're thinking of
this stuff and i've
watched pretty much everything uh first
of all it's hilarious
right it's entertaining uh and i think
part of the point of barstool is to make
people laugh and you know dave
and many others have said it multiple
times like just to give people a break
from life
right and i think that you guys are
obviously doing a great job of that how
do you personally come up with these
ideas like
peeing in a cup sending your poop
somewhere going to the porn convention
you know i probably should like do more
context on peeing in a cup and sitting
my poop because that just sounds without
context that sounds
wild um but uh
what so dude so
it really is like i kind of think of
myself and i don't know if this is right
or wrong
uh but i kind of think of myself as just
like
working for myself i work for barcelona
i work for the bigger
company you know and i and it's really
out of just loyalty to dave because he
he really took a chance on on hiring me
at fresh out of college and he's
he just been like the best boss and
really partner uh because he's really a
creative partner because it's like
he's he's not bossing me around which i
appreciate and
it's he's like gained a lot of uh
loyalty from me
just by the fact that he's kind of like
stays out of the way and he's is very
supportive but he's not
uh telling me what to do and as a
creative person and as a just a creative
for my profession that's i think it's
the only way it would work and so i'm
loyal to him and definitely to the brand
because that's what's given me the
opportunities
um but i kind of feel like my own boss
in the sense of
i wake up every day and i make my own
schedule for the most part i
do radio every day um but besides that i
i decide what i'm going to do i decide
what i'm going to work on i decide where
my priorities are
i decide what's in you know important
for me to post on how many times i'm
going to post every sing
every single decision that i make i make
on my own volition
um and so that's kind of
uh it's kind of the feeling i wake up
with is
is almost like i'm a you know
entrepreneur in the sense of growing the
uh my own brand and um so when i'm
making these decisions you just talk
about what am i gonna
you know what are you gonna work on or
what i'm gonna do or how do these videos
come to light
a lot of them are just like
you know they they just fit in with what
i'm trying to at the moment like my
almost it sounds corny it's not really
how i think
but like a business initiative like what
am i trying to do right now and then
it's like okay what is the content that
aligns with that
yeah makes a lot of sense how has that
changed in terms of uh
quarantine obviously people were just
sitting at home
how did that affect you as you made some
of the content
i went back to north carolina um i saw
everything was getting bad in new york i
kind of saw the writing on the wall
so there was like this weird um
text that was going around i think you
probably got it like a couple times it
was like
it was about some dude had like an uncle
who sat in on a lunch
what cuomo was at and they were talking
about shutting down the bridges and
tunnels
yeah i got it yeah so i got that text
like
six times and i was like all right well
i'm getting out of here and so i rented
a car
for a week in advance i was like if this
everything keeps progressing at the rate
it's progressing
a week from now i'm gonna be wanting to
get out of here and i'm worried all the
cars are gonna get rented up so i
rented a car for a week in advance and
sure enough
a week later they didn't shut down the
bridges and tunnels but it was getting
getting worse and so i just took that
car and i drove to north carolina
and then i got to north carolina and all
my neighbors saw me and then like
so my parents get in there like wait
don't you live in new york city
because this was like the worst thing in
the world to have someone from new york
city come to your neighborhood
but uh so anyways i was back in north
carolina and uh i do what i could i
picked up golf which is like now that's
pretty much exclusively what i'm doing
is golf
i see the strokes hat on and uh there's
a lot of people asking if you're gonna
join the pga
yeah that's my goal so what happened to
me
is i went back home north carolina
obviously the one of the only things to
do right now is play golf
i'm hanging out with some of my boys
we're actually in chapel hill
and uh and every time my whole life
people ask me if i want to play golf
i always say i never played before and i
don't want to hold you guys up
you know what i'm saying like i don't
want to i don't want to go out there and
then it's my first time
you guys know how to play i'm spraying
balls everywhere i don't know the rules
and then
all of a sudden your whole golf
experience is about helping me
learn how to play so every time i've
been asked my whole life i've been like
thanks but no thanks i don't want to
ruin your time
so i said this this time but these are
like my best friends and they're like
dude come on like shut up let's you can
drink some beers and we'll come and
let's play golf
first time ever playing and i
immediately fell in love with it i was
like dude this is the best
sport ever this is the best sport of all
time you're outside
you're with your friends it's not super
physically demanding although
i have got hurt multiple times since i
started playing
um you can take it as seriously as you
want to take it it's just
uh it's just a beautiful game it's
mental i mean
i was like oh this is my calling in life
and i'm 27 but i just figured out that
this is actually
what i'm supposed to do with my life is
be a golfer
and so on that day that very day
my first time ever playing and i wasn't
good i wasn't like oh you're a natural
nothing like that
i just fell in love with it and i said
my
calling in life is to be
on the golf course every day ncb and the
way that you do that
is either you know bitcoin goes to 45
trillion i can do whatever i want or
you become a professional golfer so i
said okay i'm going to become a
professional golfer
because that is my calling it's a gut
feeling i'm 27
i know i have uphill battle but
i'm gonna be ten years from now
on the pga tour and that's why i and i
made that decision
i put that announcement out that's
probably two months ago and since then
that's
uh what i've been working on almost
exclusively is to go to the pga tour
so when you're in north carolina uh it's
much easier there's golf courses
everywhere and uh you can just get your
car drive there
in new york city there's not exactly a
lot of golf courses everywhere so how do
you continue that
journey to the pga tour in new york city
well dude i kept getting hurt
at the beginning so how do you get hurt
you got to explain for those that don't
know how do you get hurt playing
i don't know i mean that's what i said
too i was when you think about golf
especially coming from like football
background you think about
it just like a leisurely easy game that
old men play
so i trust me i was more surprised than
anybody
but uh i hadn't been doing anything i
was just in
i was in in content creator shape i
wasn't playing sports i wouldn't do
anything so
you go out there it's a pretty athletic
movement if you want to want to do it
right right you know i wouldn't even do
it right i was trying to but a swing of
a golf club is a lot of like
uh you know stability in your core a lot
of hips
and if you don't have those muscles
ready
um you you'll find out you'll get pretty
sore and you might even get hurt but
here's the real issue
once i decide to go pro and people
listening to this are like is he serious
does he really think he can go pro he
can't go pro
the answer is yeah i am being serious so
whenever i and now we can talk more
about why i'm serious if you want but
um when i first started i was like okay
so i know this is going to take
this is going to take work it doesn't
just happen so
i immediately after starting playing one
day i think i started on like a saturday
and on monday i was like okay let's
start
the golf career and so i think i was
putting in like six to eight hours of
golf a day
um and that and so basically i went from
zero
to 100 and so that's how i got hurt it
wasn't necessarily just like
18 holes with my buddies like i was like
playing way too much my body was not
even close to being ready
and i just hit the accelerator too fast
and so then i really did
i ended up uh pulling a muscle in my
back i had some really bad tendonitis in
my knees
and then to top it all off dude one
night i was
i came home from one of these golf trips
and my mom so i'm staying at my parents
house from for coronavirus
she made my she like changed the sheets
while i was out
so you know and that's a good mom move
and i'm not hating on my mom
i'm very appreciative of my mom she
changed my sheets they needed to be
changed i appreciate that i'm a grown
man i can handle my own
but she would do me a favor so i go into
and she she put clean sheets down the
bed so i go in to get in bed that night
and i took a melatonin right before i
went to bed
because i was like you know i'm trying
to get some sleep fast
i get in the bed she tucked the sheets
so tight under the bottom of the bed
like you ever been to a hotel in the and
the sheets are super tight at the bottom
of the bed
yeah you're doing like uh you're like
fighting with the sheets to get them
untucked
it was i don't know if the blanket was
too long
because she was too long it was almost
like she tucked it all the way in from
the bottom of the bed and then all the
way back all the way to the top i
couldn't get these things out
so eventually i just went to sleep and
my toes
were cranked back literally like this
they were cranked under the sheets and
all night they were cranked but the
melatonin i just i just
i passed out i wake up in the middle of
night in excruciating pain
i got turf toe from my mom cheeks and
i'm not kidding
i got actual turf toe because my my
thing was pulled back for so long and so
i had to deal with turf toe
i mean it's just been a myriad of
terrible issues so
and it when you reach the pga tour no
one's going to be able to say it wasn't
a it wasn't a journey
that you didn't work hard for this no
one
no one's going to be able to say that
it's going to be a modern miracle if i
can even swaying a golf club in
over a month so what are you going to do
in new york
so i'm back here now um
and i have a plan to there's there's a
course
a nine-hole course in new jersey it's
like 25 minutes from me
that i've worked it out with them that
they're gonna let me come out there and
my my plan is every day i'm gonna go out
in the morning
i'm gonna play mine you know 9 18 holes
of on course experience
i'll go in i do a radio show every day
at one o'clock the yak on sirius xm
for barstool um with a bunch of other
great guys
and then after that there's another
place called
golf and body and it is a
it's a membership only club in new york
city it's very
nice very like luxurious they
they reached out to me um and they
you know they worked it out for me
because i can't pay it it's a very
expensive place so i can't personally
front the bill so they're letting me get
in kind of uh
you know just out of good faith i guess
oh and they're they're just being nice
guys so they're letting me go there for
free
um but when you make it to the pga tour
they're gonna be able to say yeah
they're to say hey we raised as i said
as they said i said hey man so part of
my like you know i told you i'll make my
own boss whatever
uh you know part of my thing with
barstool
is that um they
i can't advertise i can't just like
advertise for whoever so i told golf and
body i was like
i can't like stop at advertise for you
guys you're like no
all we want is whenever you go pro just
say that you came to golf and body i was
like done
so anyways an afternoon i'll go there
and they have everything they have
hitting bays they have
a p like pga professional instructors
they have
uh putting greens they have a workout
facility that hopefully whenever the gym
is open back
up i can utilize um and they have locker
rooms everything so it's like a full
indoor golf place it's honestly not
ideal for someone who's trying to go pro
because you really want to be out on the
course
and but for new york city it's the best
possible way to continue to be good at
golf especially during the winter
which you know is i'm not gonna be
outside here
so eight hours a day i could think i
could put into golf
all right so there's a lot of people who
watch this and say uh
caleb is always joking around but i
think he's serious
and the question then is why is he
serious about this
so dude it's really like my whole life
i'm still new i've got to figure out a
better way to answer this question
because i'm getting asked a lot
i haven't nailed my answer but really
the truth is that
when i play golf that day and this
sounds maybe stupid when i play golf
today
and i was thinking about it i had this
like
emotional physical when i had the
it was like this idea was like i should
go pro i should like do this with my
life
and then all of a sudden like all these
mechanisms
inside me and my brain starts churning
and then
everything was like it just made sense
it was like a gut feeling it was a
literal
gut feeling and then you know i'm
thinking about it and all of a sudden
the ideas start flowing you know if you
ever had a
you know an idea and then all of a
sudden you might be driving in the car
and you have an idea whether it's about
your work or whatever
and then all of a sudden that idea and
you're like oh my god this is great and
then i could do this and i could do this
and so i had that with golf it was like
a gut
feeling that was like yo this is it
makes sense because
i love being obviously have athletic
background i love the athletic part of
it
i love the competition part of it i love
the camaraderie part of it
i love um the fact that
it's outside it's it's it's very like
you feel like you're kind of
in nature even though you're not which
is perfect for me because i
in theory like nature but then when i'm
actually like back in north carolina we
go like hiking and stuff i'm like
this is like there's like too many bugs
out here you know so
golf is like the perfect balance of
nature for me you get off your phone
which is a big thing for me because i'm
always on my phone for work so
to be able to get off the phone so just
lifestyle-wise
it worked for me and then i was like i
can do this for my work
like i'm a i'm a content creator there's
a
there's a lot of golf space to be had
for making content i can do this
and still do a good job at my work for
barstool and this is something where
you know i can basically continue on the
path i'm on but also
start a new journey i'm like yo i'm 27.
this might take me 10 say it takes me 20
years maybe tell me
it takes 23 years i think at 50 you can
play on a senior tour
say i don't get on any tours until i'm a
senior
you know i know 50 year olds like
they're relatively still young
especially ones who are like going for
their dreams and and like doing stuff
like
it seems 27 thinking about being 50
seems
so far off but then i know these 50 year
olds who are like
totally young and totally like going
forward and in good shape
i'm like don't i what i want to do at 47
do i still want to be going to college
campuses
and like i mean these videos are good
but i am going to get aged out of some
of it
isn't it good to be like uh
on the pga tour or on a senior tour at
50 like isn't that a good lifestyle that
i could be working towards
while maintaining my goals here and
and i think also came back to just my
innate
um what i'm good at and i think that's
something i've really been focusing on
a lot recently is trying to just focus
in on things that i'm really good at
um and put my attention there because i
know that
from my experience you know what i what
i put my
attention on i get better at and what i
focus on
is improves but you know i've also put
my attention and focused on things that
i'm not
inherently good at or i'm not naturally
uh great at and so then i watch those
things go from bad to average and i'm
not really seeing a huge value add to my
life
um one thing that i don't think i'm that
good at that i do every day
is radio i do it every day uh and i
wouldn't do it but i like the guy so
much
on the show that i deal with it's like
big cat and roan and
kb nick and brandon walker are the guys
and it's just like a good group of guys
i feel like i'm hanging out with my
friends
why do you why do you feel like you're
not good at it it's just not natural to
me
um you know i'm not like a natural
i'm not like a take artist you know like
people who are
are like they can just give you like a
fire take about anything
just right off the top of their head
it's just not my
it's not my thing and it's just not i
know that about myself uh i'm more like
i like to like think of like
i don't see bigger ideas but like you
know something that might take a little
bit more time or like
a a video idea that's that's kind of
more like convoluted and has more layers
to
it that's that's what i'm good at so
anyways
long-winded way of saying i do that just
because i love the guys and they're part
of my and they're just like my friends
um but anything else that i do and i'm
putting my attention on i'm really
trying to make sure that i'm i have a
chance of being like the best at it or
like one of the best at it
and that goes for videos uh that i'm
making
but also for golf that's my it's my
personality it's like
it's a kind of like a thinking game is
some
athleticism i'm not like the most i play
card football but i'm not really like
the most athletic
guy of all time i'm just i have like
enough athleticism
the thing that got me far in football
was the mental side of the game
and i was a hard worker uh i was really
good at the mental side of the game and
i was a really hard worker
i see those qualities i'm above the
threshold for golf so i'm not
i'm athletic enough to be elite player
but
um you know i'm not super athletic and
then the mental side though i think i
could really
thrive and i think i could really thrive
in the hard working side which i know
i'm a hard worker so anyways it aligns
for me
with what i'm inherently good at and i
want to start
doing things that are a sustainable one
but also two
that i can if i do put my attention and
my focus on it
then i can really become really good at
it
you know what i'm saying so before we
talk about bitcoin
where are we starting on the golf side
like what are you shooting when you go
for 18 holes right now and then what do
we got to get one
so 21. here's my hat right here 51
strokes
i have to lose 51 strokes to be a
scratch player
uh that's what the 51 strokes is all
about so my goal
uh was june 18th next year
i want to be scratch now i didn't
foresee being
sidelined with for two months of that 12
months with injuries
um so maybe that's going to be hard it
was going to be hard to begin with but i
said if i can't get to scratch in one
year
i mean this is a far off goal i'm not an
idiot i know what it it's
to be in the pga that's tough so if i
can't
show some type of inherent ability to
play
and hard work that it takes and skill
level to get to scratch in a year which
is
almost impossible but you got to
remember i'm playing a lot
then maybe this ain't i ain't cut out
for golf as much i thought it was
so that was my goal i do need to uh
get back playing maybe i'll give myself
like a breakfast ball
on one or two months but um 121
is my score i my goal is to be at
at uh i want to be a scratch player
by june 18 2021 and then four years
after that i want to be
on some type of tour and then i'm gonna
give myself
uh five years from there to go be on the
pga tour that puts me at a pga player at
37 years old which
is possible there are plenty of 37 and
up players on the pga tour
so uh what's the best score you've shot
so far
121. okay so 121 is the best and now
we've got to go the first time i've ever
kept score
oh okay all right all right that's fair
look hey keep in mind i'm new dude
i've only kept score uh because i'm so
bad that when i go out and play
i'm not keeping score because it hurts
my morale so i'm gonna give you
uh you're a better man than me because
the only golf where i've ever kept score
is uh like actually tried to keep scores
we used to play something called speed
golf which
everyone plays normal golf they count
the number of strokes
right so you know part three whatever
what we did a couple of times in
in high school is we play speed golf
which is when you tee off
from the tee box the timer starts and
you can run all over the course do
whatever it doesn't matter how many
strokes it's how long does it take from
when you tee off to you put the ball in
but the only difference or the only
caveat to that is
when you tee off you've got to finish a
beer before you put the ball in
so every hole is one beer and it's timed
rather than strokes
yeah absolute madness by about like you
know whole six or seven
we used to go to like you know one of
these like executive par 3 courses
that's like you know nine holes or
whatever
complete madness by the time you get
about halfway through yeah beard
uh the golfing is also like it's an easy
way to get carried away with the
drinking
it's very you find it easy way we played
so the the weekend i hurt my back we
were in pinehurst
uh we have some some golf stuff going on
barstool classic is that pinehurst so i
was there
and over the course of the weekend i get
in on friday
and we played uh i played 36 holes on
friday i got in
with my first tee time was at one right
played at 18
uh at one and then we got finished
around five or something and we're
walking back off the course and we're
like dude we really want to play again
found some random dudes that we had
never met like you guys want to if i can
get us a tee time because pinehurst was
like
helping us out i was like you guys would
play with us played
36 on friday the next day i played 45 on
saturday the point here is at the 45
holes you can imagine
the drinking it gets intense and then um
and i think we played whatever the
remainder is played 97 holes for the
whole weekend
and dude i don't know if my body hurt
more or my brain dude from
it's easy way to get carried away i
think that's why a lot of guys like i
think 50
of golfers are actually they just like
drinking for sure
absolutely um all right talk to me about
bitcoin
uh and the context here is uh marty bent
which many people in the bitcoin
community will know
uh used to work at bar stool and he red
pilled
a good number of people at bar stool uh
you were one of them so tell us kind of
like what was the first time you ever
heard of bitcoin
what were those conversations like marty
uh like as well well first of all you're
the first person to
ever say tell me what you think about
bitcoin because
i'm used to people saying caleb shut up
about bitcoin
caleb shut up we don't care we get it we
know
um so marty was
hired at barstool we called him i know
him as bitcoin marty
you know him as marcus dent i know him
as bitcoin marty
bitcoin marty got hired at barstool
literally as
he had like some type of fake job that
we were paying him for
on paper his job was the crypto guy
because dave was getting into crypto
and we had another guy named lightswitch
lou who's also
he's also doesn't work at barcelo
anymore who's the one who knew
marty and brought him in he was in
crypto and then
at barstool marty got me and the crypto
maybe a few other guys
um and i had like the most classic
story getting into bitcoin because marty
comes along
i meet him like what's this guy's deal
oh this is bitcoin marty well what's
bitcoin
he starts doing tell me about bitcoin
i'm like all right i'll throw a few
bucks at it
cool well then it was what 2017 in the
fall
and so i throw like whatever 100 bucks
at bitcoin
all of a sudden 100 bucks is you know
150 bucks
pretty quick like within a couple like a
week or something it was like
right when it was going off so i was
like oh this is like
i got to get on this train now like this
is this train is leaving the station and
i have to
put everything i own into bitcoin so
this is my personality you can already
tell by
going all the way on golf i think all my
money that i have
all of it here's all the money i have
and i put it on the b i put in a bitcoin
every single dollar that i had to my
name that wasn't tied up in something
else
well then bitcoin starts kind of slowing
down right it didn't crash but it was
like slowing down
i'm not talking about the over the
course of months i mean
like a couple days it was slowing down
and i wasn't getting that
that that hit i was like the hit of
adrenaline when i was going up i was
like
watching coinmarketcap.com and all of a
sudden i'm seeing bitcoin
you know plus .04
uh growth and then i'm seeing all these
other coins go 32
25 whatever so i and i
asked marty i say bitcoin marty what's
the deal with these other coins
why why are they going up so much are
they going to be the big ones
and i don't know at this point he's
giving me the speech about what
cryptocurrency is what blockchain
blockchain technology is what a
decentralized currency could mean for
humanity
and all at this point i'm thinking about
is the green
plus however much percent and he says
caleb
dude do not go into these all coins he's
like if i can give you any piece of
advice
it would be hold your bitcoin do not go
into these all coins if you want to go
into the all coins
this monero might have some value
because it's
you know of its secret nature and it's
still you know
whatever he's like but i wouldn't even
he's like if you want to put some money
in that okay
if you want to diversify but he's like
i'm telling you man these all coins
ain't where it's at it's just all right
bitcoin marty i said you've got me far
enough
i'll i'm done taking your advice like
you got me into bitcoin i've i've abused
you
and your brain almost cale's brain's
taken over now
so i put all the money that was in
bitcoin move it to the all coins
right and i'm not talking about like the
altcoins that are
uh at first it was like ripple
and ethereal well then those get boring
you know and then you see the ones that
are hitting 300 percent
so before you know it i get carried away
i got
all my money's tied up in these random
and
i've got the ones that you have to get a
download like software onto your
computer just so you can get on to the
uh the exchange where they hold this
coin
i was in some oh it was like q cash
something that was in china and it was
like
you had to download their service thing
was called like liquid
it has since like went out of business
and they like they sent an email like if
you had money here
sorry you can no longer access it
anyways but
all you need to know is that i've moved
my money over here bitcoin tanks
obviously the altcoins tank even worse i
lost
everything i lost every dollar of
everything that i had boom poof out the
window
cryptocurrency and that's how i got into
bitcoin
all right you're still here though so
explain what happens
after you lose everything i lose
everything
and i have to laugh at myself because
i'm like i'm an idiot
proven time and time again idiot um
never cease to amaze myself idiot
then it goes on bitcoin kind of uh goes
down i can't remember what it was at at
the time
i want to say it was like 4 000 or
something low
and uh and so he and and bitcoin marty
you know
he's popular at barstow whenever uh
bitcoin is going up
because i think dave had bought some big
cat bought some but then
bitcoin crashes you know i don't think
anyone's gonna say it to his face but
you know you kind of have a little bit
of like you know
this guy got everyone on bitcoin we all
lost all our money
um and anyway he ended up leaving he's
in and
but i love marty so and it wasn't he
wasn't fired because of bitcoin i
came i think he left on his own volition
i think he took another job
but everyone was like freaking bitcoin
marty lost us all this money so
probably a year later i was like or
maybe even six months later like let's
go get
some a beer and let's hang out cause i
haven't seen you i miss you
so we're talking i'm like so what's
going on bitcoin dude like
tell me what you think now and he just
really
he talked to me about one how he had
always felt the same thing
uh about it his thoughts hadn't changed
but then he's really talking to me about
some of the deeper issues with bitcoin
and and some of the
what he believes is are you know some of
the progress is like society could make
from
from adopting bitcoin and he gave me
some kind of materials i could look at
and look more into and
for the first time ever he told me about
um kind of the the
stages of currency that um the united
states has went through
uh over the years and how basically
right now we're not backed up by
anything and
he really kind of like put some real
thoughts in my mind that were outside of
the just the numbers going up
and so he kind of gave me some stuff to
look at so i go and i look at it and i'm
doing more research and so i start
buying in a little bit
you know at low and i'm like you know i
kind of do still think this is
this it is something um
and then i kind of just slowly getting
in kind of watching it go
up and then i'm really thinking more
about it and i don't have and i know
you're showing this why i'm a fan of
your shows you have
experts come on and they have so much
extensive knowledge of the
uh what's what's happening that's not me
but i do think i have a little bit of
knowledge about
or at least i have a feel it's more of a
feel thing
of what's popular and trends and things
that are
uh that have legs you know with what's
coming up
whether it's like we get on we got on
tick tock really early
not really really early but like once we
saw it we were on tick tock uh
and i said we me and another guy who i
do a thinker account with
or a daily fact account or something
like tick tock or even like a new band
you know you see something like this has
legs something about it is exciting and
it's
and it and it makes sense on a lot of
levels and i could see this being big
um that's kind of how i felt about
bitcoin still and i still do to this day
and it's the main reason why i'm in it
is because
i look at bitcoin and i say you know
there's obviously some issues here
uh it's obviously very speculative but
when you look at the next generation of
kids i have a 10 year old 10 years
younger than me brother
and his world is so different than mine
with
technology and ever you know all of
their relationships
my little brother's really good about it
getting with his friends being with him
on a personal level but
i see his friends too it's all phone
everything's phone and i'm kind of in
the generation
where or my age group is it's a lot of
phone
but there's also a lot of personal
interaction 10 years younger than me
it's almost
90 phone it's they talk to each other on
snapchat in the same room
or everything that's happening is
digital
10 years younger than that i mean they
have no chance of human to human
interaction how we used to do it so
i'm thinking about all right these kids
are they gonna think about when they
think about money or they think about an
asset like i personally and i don't know
up from down so don't take my word for
i'm just telling you what i think
um i kind of think that bitcoin has more
legs as an asset than it does as a
currency
just for the reason that when you talk
if i told my little brother about the
value of gold
it would be the actual goal it's like
hard to get it's like what do you get a
gold bar it doesn't really make sense
it's not like apple it's not intuitive
it's like you have to do more explaining
to uh
to explain to someone this is gold this
is how you get it this is why it's
valuable
then you would have to do for bitcoin
and pretty much
at the end of the day you're coming back
to the same argument of why is
why is gold valuable if i really had to
explain to my little brother or someone
who's younger than him
i would eventually have to say well it's
basically just valuable because everyone
else says it is
you know that's the same thing for
bitcoin
because there is no inherent value of
you know holding a bar or
it's i think it just for people who are
in the digital age
whereas people now and older than me
probably think about well it's just
digital so it's really not there
it's if it's ethereal it's in the
floating in the
air you know it doesn't make sense it's
not
it's not real it's not grounded in real
life
my take is that life grounded in real
life
is disappearing very quickly and i think
10 years from now 15 years from now
the amount of life that's happening as
we understand it
in actual you know it's it's not that
there's a digital world over here on the
right
and then everything that is in the
digital world is just a reflection of
what's happening in our actual
reality i think that the reality of
what's
actually happening what actually matters
is going to be almost
entirely in the digital world for
example
right now you look at like a twitter
twitter is a social media that you kind
of report
you report back on your thoughts about
what's happening in our
material world or in our reality but
then you look at something like which i
think
twitter's on the way out i do i hate
twitter it's getting so terrible
i get on it because it work if it wasn't
for work i wouldn't even be on twitter
but tick tock you know i don't know
where it's heading it looks like it's
kind of
where with president trump right now but
tick tock it's not a reflection of
what's going on
in the real world it is its own world
tik tok
is its own entire world similar to
youtube
youtube is you go into youtube and it's
like that is its own
reality it's not a report back
necessarily on what's happening
in the real world so i'm just thinking
about
the future i see it as
that we're going to be living inside the
youtube in the tick tocks and
just the internet sphere that is going
to be the basis of our reality
and it makes so much more sense
intuitively
to have something that's a store of
value like bitcoin
that exists and and works with that
world
opposed to a gold that
you know i'm not saying gold's not gonna
be valuable but uh
you know it just doesn't make quite as
much
i guess intuitive sense
yeah it's almost like um it's really
interesting to hear you say this because
you're the first person i've heard
articulated this way but i think you're
dead on in that
there's an entire generation of people
that their default for
value is in the analog world right so
kind of this idea like
the digital world isn't valuable it's
not real like you kids are crazy
but when you flip around to the youngest
generations the default is
all of the values in the digital world
and so i joke all the time you know
enough you said that's so much better
than i did
no no listen but i i think that you know
the best example
is like how many people see when it
comes to work
like somebody like wants them to print
out a piece of paper sign it and then
like
fax it or copy it back right i think
there's a whole generation of people
like that's stupid just send it to me
digitally
right like that like it's such a better
process and so that
mentality is going to permeate into even
assets and things like that
and also what's the difference between
buying
a stock on an app on your phone
versus buying some other asset right the
experience is very similar and yes the
asset itself
is different but i think that there's an
entire generation of people that are
growing up
where maybe your dad or my dad or
somebody else
would call like a broker and be like you
know hey can you buy
xyz you know asset for me and it was a
relationship
where you were talking to a human in
order to get access to something
now i don't need to talk to anybody
right i literally just go right into the
phone and i can do all kinds of things
including send you money i can buy
things i can do all of this
never leave my couch not to talk to
anybody and so naturally the assets i
think that interface with that
are going to be attractive right because
it's just a different way of growing up
uh from a technology standpoint
100 i i you said it 10 times better than
i said it but
um it really is the world is shifting to
you know where the where the most
valuable
whether it's you know an asset or it's a
financial value but just
it's and i think it's kind of
unfortunate because i don't necessarily
know that it's
right or i don't necessarily know that
it's good but i think that just if you
look at where things are trending
people are putting more and more value
of what you know what they think about
themselves
what self-value is starting to align
with the analog world
and you know value of of what is
important
in life you know is like you know what
what should i do today well
it's not necessarily i think it's
trending about
what i should do today and what if
that's going to
the value of my day's time my time the
value of my time is starting to go
analog world so it's like all value is
trending in that direction so
it only makes sense that you know a
store of value would
also live in that world and i like i
said i don't necessarily think that
that's a good thing
but i do think that's where things are
trending
yeah and i think the part that that's
really interesting too is if you go back
uh obviously there's now the uh the
infamous video that dave made
uh about bitcoin in 2017. right he's so
good still plays and like the part about
it is
he's just so honest he's like i don't
even know what bitcoins are like i don't
you know and you can tell that uh
whether it's marty or somebody else has
told him enough where he's got kind of
pieces of it
right right but then he's talking about
like i don't know somebody's just got a
computer and they're just mining the
bitcoins and then you know they just
keep
and he's going through this and what you
start to realize is like
ultimately what's driving his interest
at that exact moment is like the price
is going up i think even he says
something like you know everyone's
getting rich but i'm not gonna stand by
and let everyone else get rich
right but now all of a sudden as price
moves people become interested and then
some portion of those people get
educated right like
you you pretty much outlined a perfect
example where
uh you're staring at a screen and when
things are going up 30 40 50 you know
300
or whatever there's just a certain part
portion of the population that looks
it's like
hey i'm not going to stand by but then
once you actually understand
what are these things and kind of what
is the value
then it's like oh you know what this
makes a lot of sense right and then they
kind of then they're converted
um in terms of that thought process and
they stick around and so i think that
like
that just is a natural market cycle and
and the price movements
are the reason why people come in right
and whether that's good or not it's just
a fact of life
um and ends up being uh being valuable i
think in the in the long run
yeah the volatility is like the best pr
team ever it really is
i mean even if it's going down if it's a
huge crash it's like
you know it's it's great pr for bitcoin
um
i caught 100 percent agree with you let
me ask this
um in terms of uh when you think of
investing
obviously the bitcoin store you told us
what do you like what else do you do
do you think about stocks or cash or
real estate like how do you think about
investing in general and really from the
perspective of
i'm only a couple years older than you i
think a lot of people would look at
um kind of these content creators
whether they work at barstool or
elsewhere
and they kind of just write everyone off
like all these millennial kids they
don't know what they're doing
you know of course they're just buying
bitcoin and tesla right it's kind of
like that the joke
in in the circles of older folks how do
you think about
investing and for saving and kind of
like what do you do
um yeah so i can tell you i can't tell
you what's the best thing to do
but i can tell you what i do um because
i don't know what's probably the
smartest thing to do what i've
what i do is you know i i'm
involved in my work uh 401k
i don't want to be it's the one thing i
make i like make myself do and i i do an
ira too
so it's like i don't want to be i
actually didn't do it for a couple years
even though it was available to me
which was probably dumb but because i
just feel like
i hate i hate giving that up uh that
money and then
that investment that seems so like with
the world we're living in how fast
things are going it seems
like i'm like there's no chance that
this is going to be worth it
but i do it as like that's my safe play
that's like my all right you're doing
this because you you're
doing something in life that's safe um
so i do do that uh i do hold bitcoin
and uh and then uh i
am the next thing i want to do is i do
want to uh
buy something you know whether it's land
or uh
you know a house not not a house to to
live in but
um you know whether it's i know some i
have some friends who are like
starting getting to like owning
properties renting out properties it's
something i'm interested in i'm reading
about right now i don't know enough
about it
to guarantee i'm just looking at my
books down here but
um i'm reading about right now trying to
learn more about it
but the number one thing that i invest
in and uh
is is literally uh i put back into
myself
and just just in terms of uh
you know what foods i'm eating um
you know what i'm willing to pay for for
you know physical training or
if it's you know a mentor or a class or
um that's where and i'm not saying like
that's how i'm thinking about it if you
really look on paper where does my money
go
it really does go towards things that
you could consider an
investment quote unquote just back into
myself
um hoping that you know that i'm going
to become
a better person and i'm gonna become a
little bit more equipped to deal with
the circumstances
of where you really make money which is
um you know in everyday decisions
and you know for me in my profession
like creatively like
you can't conjure up a creative idea
it's
it's not how it works so you really just
have to what i've learned is you really
have to put yourself
in the best position and if it does
happen that you're
you did your part you can only do so
much you can't
force a creative idea a good one
you really just and for me that just
means you know
it's it's eating healthy it's getting
good sleep it's exercising it's just
doing the
stuff everyone knows meditating uh it's
just it's stuff that everyone knows but
no one wants to do
um and that stuff does cost money if you
want to do it right so
for sure so that's that's honestly if
you just look at like
where i'm investing that's where uh
my my actual the most money goes is that
kind of stuff and then
you know i do like i got in on robin
hood when the stock market crashed for
coronavirus i'm i'm pretty much out
uh because um
i don't like it makes me nervous like
what's going on in stock
once it started i made a ton of money
because i just because of my timing not
because i'm smart
but obviously it crashed i went in i
made a lot of money because it's
rebounded so quickly
i got out pretty much uh whenever it
stopped making sense
why things were going up i didn't like
that obviously dave's still crushing
or he says he is i don't know and then
but i'm out of that i still have and of
course you know i'm i
like pin the company that owns us like i
um i'm in pen so that that type of thing
but
really um the most of my
investment is is in trying to because i
think i'm going to personally make more
money wise i'm going to make more money
from like doing a really good job at bar
stool
than i'm probably going to make from
hitting some
stock or something like that if i can
really do
i mean people saw the caller daddy saga
if people remember that
and they were like astounded with what
these girls are making
you know i'm not making that type of
money but uh it's possible and and
dave's the type of guy
who would be more than happy to pay me
a million like these guys would be more
than happy to pay you
whatever you're worth it's not like
they're trying to rip you off or
so if i can make myself valuable and i
can do a really good job
for them then i'll get paid and i'm
gonna make more from that
than i'm ever gonna make from i would
say tesla but tesla's going up pretty
good
[Laughter]
i love it no and it makes sense right
it's
if you can increase your earning power
uh that is probably the number one lever
you can pull
right and so it's actually uh incredibly
intelligent
in terms of kind of what you do for a
living and if you can improve that
um i think it ends up being a very smart
uh investment uh before i wrap up i
asked everyone the same two questions
uh the first is what's the most
important book you've ever read
whoa um
i would say the mo the mo the one that
had the biggest impact on me probably
and was um
the book about steve jobs bought by
walter isaacson
because because it's a great book and
because
steve jobs was so fascinating and uh
and and just how he lived his life and
it was just
that part of it also hit me at a time in
my life where i was you know i was in
college and i was making it was towards
the end of my college run and i'm making
a lot of decisions and you're kind of i
was kind of in that point of my life
where
or it's one of the many points of your
life i guess where you're kind of
you're very open and receptive to um
some like a book or where a book can
really can change your life
it's like when you're in like middle
school a song can really change your
life you know you really start living by
that justin timberlake song whatever
you know that's that becomes your mantra
well then when you're in college a book
can really change your life so i would
say
i've read a lot of you know books that i
love but i would say that that one
really changed my perspective in a lot
of ways about
um how i was approaching life just
because probably
at what point i read it i love that
answer
uh one more question that you get to ask
me one to finish up but uh this one's
more fun
aliens believer or non-believer well i
don't think you have a choice anymore
you might want to change that
question why
i mean they're they're proven real
it's like uh they're basically here
right they basically showed up already
they've been here yeah it's like old
news it's like no one even cares it's
like
that that's hilarious uh yeah i'm
definitely in on aliens i've been in it
first of all i've been in on aliens
before
um before
it was popular but now if you're not in
on aliens you're kind of like
you know i i my parents are like uh
just to use them as an example i don't
think they were in on aliens at all
but now i think that they're in on
aliens because i think you have to it's
like
no we we've discovered spaceships and
also here's a video of them
it's like it's almost like the people
who were into aliens before they were
the conspiracy theorists but now if
you're not into aliens you're a
conspiracy theorist right
it's like switched it's it's very tough
it's like uh
yeah one of the things i kind of always
tell i think about too is like
people who like are like don't believe
in evolution right
it's like for me that's it's pretty
proven it's like
i think i read something it's like
evolution is just as proven is
that h2o is water you know if you it's
like are you going to believe
you if you're going to believe h2o's
water then it's like just as proven that
evolution happened but they're still and
i'm from the south and i guess you are
too
you know it's still not super popular it
wasn't even taught to me in school
growing up
the first time i even heard about
evolution was in college
right i was studying abroad in edinburgh
scotland and they
and that's like where charles darwin's
from and all and uh
and i was like oh like i never heard
about this
evolution i learned it when i was 21
years old so
anyways uh the aliens are kind of the
same deal it's turning out to be it's
like
no they're here they've been here they
might be among us now
but we don't really you know we don't
talk about it because
it's scary here's this video no no
problem
yeah right so i would say yes of course
the audience
what uh what one question you got for me
to finish up okay
okay well first of all if we're gonna
flip the tables i'll say that i'm a big
fan of yours i told and that's how i
ended up doing this
it's not because i think you were so
interested in my bitcoin takes but i
actually reached out to you and said hey
man i'm a big fan because
i just i hate twitter i told you that
and uh
it just because it's it's just not
becoming enjoyable now it's like it's
i don't even need to explain people on
twitter know what it's like
but there are a few people a few people
who i enjoy their tweets
i really get enjoyment and they're from
different worlds or different things
dave my boss is one of them i always
will look and see what he's tweeting
about he's always cracks me up
uh and then you're another one just
because you know for me the bitcoin
world i know you live in it it's so
far removed from me um and so i like to
see what you got going on what i love
whenever you do
the uh the un the bull run tweet
the bull run tweets my favorite tweet on
it on the internet so
um yeah so i'm a huge fan of yours so
i'll
butter you up with that and i'll ask you
this
um what do you think is the biggest
obstacle
in the way of bitcoin uh becoming
something that
is more uh for the adoption of bitcoin
just time i think it's one of these
things where uh
in my mind it's inevitable right for a
lot of the reasons you described earlier
uh and i think ultimately there's like
this global gain theory going on
where governments are just going to
print so much money and there's going to
be so many manipulated economies and
currencies that
eventually people are just going to
start opting into something that can't
be manipulated
uh i don't know how long that takes it's
not gonna happen tomorrow but
you know could be 10 years away 20 years
away whatever it is
uh but but i think that we've got to
remember kind of the rise of
currencies or assets in general take a
long time right and
bitcoin's got not only the time obstacle
but also needs time for people to build
the infrastructure and kind of all the
things necessary to make it
easier right so um we can't send bitcoin
back and forth between these
you know random string of letters and
numbers and people's hearts are like
jumping out of their skin because
they're scared they're gonna send it to
the wrong person
right you just gotta like all the
stuff's gotta improve and so it just
takes time
um which for humans i think we hate that
answer because it's like we wanna know
like what could we do
uh but ultimately it's just like we just
got to keep doing what we're doing and
be patient
um and you know look bitcoin went from
you know
a third of a cent to set like eleven
thousand dollars right now
like that's insane over you know 10 11
years um
but i think that that's just getting
started right and it's kind of like if
you went you looked at the internet in
the early 90s you were like
wow you know i could send a message to
somebody and now you look and like you
and i live you know
90 of our life on our phones on the
internet you know talking to people and
doing all kinds of crazy stuff
like i think bitcoin's very similar you
don't think that
uh maybe my biggest worry is is
i know the government can control it um
but
you know i think governments could come
together and really
hurt the value don't you think i think
that
uh there's probably less likelihood that
they'll coordinate
but i definitely think that there will
be unilateral actions so like the united
states could ban
ownership or another country could ban
ownership or something like that
they did it to gold before right so it's
definitely an
option uh the only difference here i
think is
if a country especially like a global
superpower did that
i actually like use the example the
united states bans ownership
i think that russia and china and these
other people who don't necessarily like
the us dollar system
would immediately get together and be
like hey let's adopt the thing that the
us isn't going to use
and then we can basically like break the
world off onto this new system
uh and the us will be you know at a
disadvantage so i do think that there's
like some
game theory that plays out of just like
the first countries to adopt it
end up having an advantage and then the
first companies to like
ban it end up being at a complete
disadvantage and so
uh what everyone seems to be doing is
like um
nobody wants to take like be the first
to move right so it's kind of like
everyone's like standing in like the
okay corral at high noon you know
guns are at their hip they haven't drawn
them yet but like the second one person
starts shooting
everyone's gonna start shooting and so
it's like this weird thing we're just
kind of like waiting to see who's the
first to make a move
right can i ask you one more i know i
only get one question but i have one
more
question for you because i asked this to
bitcoin marty and i wasn't happy with
his answer
all right not that he answered it but i
was like
i i he didn't convince me right this is
my other
so from my perspective my idiot
perspective about bitcoin
my two uh worries about it are one i
worry about
you know i don't think that the banks
and government is they're cool with it
now where it's at now but
if it gets big i don't think they're
gonna be cool with it and then
my other worry is this and let's see if
i can do a better job of explaining this
thought
so if
bitcoin comes out and it's completely
it's kind of uh
capitalistic right it's it's it's and a
lot of people like marty think
that uh bitcoin as our financial system
could solve a lot of problems right
so if it comes out and it's kind of like
the government doesn't interfere with it
it's
my worry is this if that type of society
exists no matter what it's if it's
financial or if it's back in the old
days and it's
and it's men trying to compete for the
women right
what ends up happening is
there's the top dog saves for the women
back in the travel days there's the
alpha
and then that alpha doesn't get
uh one girl who doesn't get the most
attractive girl
he doesn't get the most attractive girl
and her
uh her sister or whatever he gets
every single girl that's how it
used to work the top dog in the in the
society
gets every woman this is way way back
you know
in bitcoin see if i can bring this full
circle here
um these are a lot of my thoughts too
are like they sound idiotic but they
have good points
in bitcoin wouldn't the top dog
if it's unregulated end up
with not a lot of bitcoin
without not uh you know a majority
bitcoin
wouldn't they end up the top most
richest guys in the world
end up with virtually all the bitcoin
wouldn't it eventually flow all the way
back it would
even people like people like me who have
a little bit wouldn't mine eventually
flow into them and then they basically
when it's all said and done
you have the the one percent of the one
percent of the one percent
has 99 of all the
well bitcoin look at the fiat legacy
system
the top you know one percent or half a
percent they control like 80 90 percent
of the world's wealth so what you just
described
essentially happened you know in legacy
finance right because that's because
this is
uh and to my point this this that's what
happens and
and uh it's just natural for the top
people to get richer the rich get richer
for sure uh i think in the bitcoin world
uh is it possible
sure uh but the one thing that bitcoin
has
that the fiat currencies don't have is
you're financially incentivized to spend
your dollars
right because they become less valuable
over time because they're being devalued
through inflation with this you know
that if you hold on to the bitcoin
because there's only 21 million
it's deflationary meaning that it'll get
more valuable over time right because as
long as demand increases fixed supply
will increase in price and so what ends
up happening is now you're
incentivized not to spend or not to be a
consumer and to be a saver
and so there's this weird dynamic where
in the legacy world
investors are rewarded and savers are
punished
now the saver actually can win in a
bitcoin denominated world and so i think
that's one of the key
differences that doesn't necessarily
mean that there's not going to be
a disparity between you know some people
with lots and lots of bitcoin and some
people with not a lot of bitcoin
right but i think that that just mirrors
you know the system that we already have
right interesting okay
all right i appreciate you letting me
get two questions off
of course where uh for like the three
people who are watching this who don't
know who you are
where uh where can they find you on the
internet i'm sure there's more than that
um but uh
kayla presley on on all uh social medias
is just my name but
um you know and i'm doing stuff for
barstool and
um i'm around i'm around hopefully in 10
years from now you
log on to whatever kind of virtual
reality
is going on and i'll be you can watch
you know the pga tour hopefully
[Laughter]
we're cheering for you man we'll have to
do this again in the future absolutely i
really appreciate it man keep doing it
keep up the hard work
keep hodling um and and just remind
people whenever bitcoin starts to go up
please remind them what to do in a bull
market